INTENTION TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
AND BRING UP A DACA AND
IMMIGRATION REFORM BILL, DO NOT.
WE WILL BRING A SOLUTION TO THE
FLOOR, ONE OF THE PRESIDENT WILL
SIGN.
WE MUST PASS THIS BUDGET
AGREEMENT FIRST.
>> THE STAKES ARE HIGH AND
LAWMAKERS STUMBLE WE CAN -- BE
HEADED TO OUR SECOND GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN OF 2018.
>> Chris: WE WILL COME TO YOU
FOR MORE DEVELOPMENTS.
LET’S GET MORE ON THE
WALL STREET PLUNGE AND WHY IT’S
CONTINUING.
DEIRDRE BOLTON JOINS US.
>> WE SAW THE FIFTH DAY OF 500
PLUS POINT SWINGS.
FOR THE DOW, FIFTH DAY OF HEAVY
SELLING.
IT’S DOWN 10% FROM ITS RECENT
RECORD HIGH WHICH MEANS IT’S
OFFICIALLY IN A CORRECTION.
THIS SUSTAINED SELLING MAKES
SOME INVESTORS ANXIOUS BUT
OTHERS SEE THE RETURN OF
VOLATILITY IS LONG OVERDUE.
WE HAD ALMOST AN ENTIRE DECADE
OF STOCKS MOVING HIGHER YEAR ON
YEAR.
STRATEGISTS TELLING IN THE U.S.
ECONOMY IS SOLID.
AMERICAN CORPORATIONS ARE
DELIVERING ON EARNINGS AND
SALES.
WE HAD 17 YEAR LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE HAVE WAGE GROWTH FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN ALMOST A DECADE
AND CORPORATE AMERICA IS BEATING
ESTIMATES.
IN THIS LAST QUARTER, ALMOST 80%
OF THE TIME.
THE HIGHER HIGHS AND LOWER LOWS,
IT’S PART OF THE INVESTING
LANDSCAPE.
THANKS TO COMPUTER GUIDED
PROGRAMS.
HUMANS WRITE TRADING PROGRAMS TO
KICK IN AUTOMATICALLY WHEN
MARKETS HIT CERTAIN LEVELS BUT
IN ONLY ONE PART OF THE MARKET.
LOOKING AT HEDGE FUNDS,
QUANTITATIVE FUNDS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALMOST 30% OF
ALL U.S. STOCK TRADES.
THAT’S DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF A
DECADE AGO.
THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS THAT
THERE’S MORE MACHINES IN THE
MIX.
THEY PROCESS IN GREATER VOLUME
WITH GREATER SPEED THAN HUMANS
AND THE RESULT IS HIGHER
VOLATILITY.
IN TODAY’S SESSION, THE BOND
MARKET FELL.
YOUR 10-YEAR TREASURY YIELDS UP.
IT AFFECTS CONSUMERS BECAUSE ALL
BORROWING GETS MORE EXPENSIVE.
MORTGAGE RATES ARE ALREADY
TAKING UP.
3.9   3.95% IN JANUARY.
THIS WEEK 4.32%.
HISTORICALLY LOW BUT IF
CONSUMERS WANT TO BORROW MONEY
TO BUY A HOUSE OR CAR, IT’S
GOING TO COST MORE.
FOR CORPORATIONS, BORROWING ALSO